[Music]
this blue-coloured mosque is known to be
such an oasis for peace
it turns the surrounding doves of pure
white
[Music]
masa sharif or the blue mosque is
located in northern afghanistan and is a
small piece of calm inside a bustling
urban area
[Music]
as you enter the park the stress of the
city melts away and is replaced by
peaceful calls to prayer and the cooing
of doves
[Music]
the mosque has many features aside from
its stunning exterior
there is a dove coop where the birds
have been fed and raised dating back to
the 12th century
and the shrine of hazrat ali who was the
cousin and son-in-law of the prophet
muhammad
the shrine can only be entered by the
faithful
[Music]
the dazzling blue hues which cover the
mosque are made up of highly detailed
and intricately placed tiles
the tiles are replaced constantly due to
weathering and often being taken by
visitors as religious mementos
although the city was constructed around
the shrine the tranquility of the blue
mosque remains quiet except for daily
calls to prayer
[Music]